unpredictable not making compromises and
using swift decisive moves
that's how flat Amir Putin's late coach
described his young pupils judo skills
at an exhibition at his former sport
school in st. Petersburg but Anatoly
Rockland's words could easily describe
the president's leadership style and
even today in his late 60s Putin likes
to be seen throwing judo champions on
the mat maintaining his image as a
strong fit macho leader the phrase my
father said to Vladimir Vladimirovich
when he congratulated him after his
inauguration was remember Volodya
it's like sports when you attack always
remember about defense when you defend
yourself remember about an attack it's a
lesson Putin seems to have taken
seriously during his two decades in
power and dominated by his goal to make
Russia great again he's improved the
lives of millions of Russians suffering
from the collapse of the Soviet Union
and provided some stability but also he
went to war in Georgia in 2008 annexed
Crimea in 2014 and backed separatists in
the east of Ukraine that same year he's
played a decisive role in the war in
Syria and has become increasingly
involved in other conflicts around the
world Putin's hero and maybe even as
example is Peter the Great who in the
17th century managed to expand the
russian empire through it wars and
invasions now three centuries later
Putin like a modern-day shark is showing
the world that Russia has listened from
the ruins of a collapse Oviatt Union a
blight Peter the Great
Putin is holding a tight grip on society
and some say his victory has come at a
great cost posturing executive images
Yeltsin's decision to handle for the
presidency to Putin was a serious
miscalculation says filmmaker vitaly
Manske who followed Putin closely during
his first year in office and made this
film Putin's witnesses this written in
those people who came up with this
successor plan want to create Putin as
we know him
of course not they were looking for a
quiet non ambitious executor who would
as yeltsin said in my film deal with
daily affairs while important things
would be done by important people this
was the scenario what happened to that
scenario we have been watching in the
past 20 years yes that Russian Russian
voters would be so spineless and soft to
surrender without a fight not only power
but their own freedoms like that forever
man skis film was never shown in Russia
a growing opposition against Putin's
rule has been met with growing
repression but while tens of thousands
took part and street protests a few
months ago Putin still has a large army
of fans
growing up in Putin's Russia this young
judo players see the president as a role
model and while he has only four years
to go until the end of his last official
term Putin's and game is as
unpredictable as his judo moves stop
fastly al Jazeera st. Petersburg